je pousse mon cadis entre les
étalage je passe de la crèmerie au rayon
maquillage dans le fond spécial
promotion soyez Bell et sans souci avec
le savon qui
rajunie je pousse mon cadis entre les
à je passe de la charcuterie au cabin
des
COG dans le fond spécial promotion un
bonheur un
chedœuvre garanti pièces main
d'u mais c'est qui qui fait la viande
c'est qui qui fait la viande mais c'est
qui qui fait la viande c'est
qui je pousse mon cadis entre les
rayonnard
j'enveloppe mes envies de papiers
d'emballage dans le fond spécial
promotion un bonheur au douce parfums
trois amours pour le
prudin mais c'est qui qui fait la viande
c'est qui qui fait la viande mais c'est
qui qui fait la viande c'est qui
je pousse mon cadis entre les pierres
tombales je pousse ma feraille entre le
bien et le
mal dans le fond spécial promotion tombe
là pour gagner gagner le Paradis
assuré mais c'est qui qui fait la viande
c'est qui qui fait la viande mais c'est
qui qui fait la viande c'est
qui c'est qui qui fait la viande mais
c'est qui qui fait la viande c'est qui
qui fait la viande c'est
qui voilà Manon lski dans Mademoiselle
Fauste deux conseils de lecture il